SIDNEY POWELL WILL JOIN US WITH
AN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW.
THAT'S ALL COMING UP.
BUT FIRST, WE START WITH AN
EGREGIOUS EXAMPLE OF FAKE PHONY,
FRAUDULENT NEWS AS ALWAYS.
JUST WHEN YOU THOUGHT IT
COULDN'T GET ANY WORSE, WELL,
THINK AGAIN.
IN ITS ONGOING EFFORTS TO SNEER,
SLANDER THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, WELL, YOU HAVE
YOUR MEDIA MOB REPORTING A
COMPLETELY FALSE STORY, AND IN
THE PROCESS, PUTTING PEOPLE'S
LIVES IN DANGER, LIKELY OUTING
THE REAL IDENTITY AND HOME
ADDRESS OF A SPY WORKING FOR THE
CIA.
JIM'S     HE IS MASQUERADING NOW
JIM'S     HE IS MASQUERADING NOH
JIM'S     HE IS MASQUERADING NOE
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT.
STRAIGHT TO FAKE NEWS CNN.
OH, LIKELY LYING AND GUILTY CNN.
IT WAS EXTRACTED WITH RUSSIA IN
2017.
BY THE WAY, SPYING ON OUR BEHALF
FOR "CONCERNS ARE
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION REPEATEDLY
MISHANDLING INFORMATION.
WELL, THAT'S A LIE.
THAT WAS FAKE NEWS AGAIN.
FAKE NEWS CNN WAS CONTRADICTED
BY "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THE TIMES REPORTING "THEY SAID
THERE WAS NO PUBLIC EVIDENCE.
OTHER AND OFFICIALS INSISTED
THAT THEY WERE THE IMPETUS FOR
THE DISTRACTION.
OH, THE MEDIA WAS RESPONSIBLE.
REPORTING FROM THE MEDIA.
THE MOB.
NOT DONALD TRUMP.
THE MEDIA MOB ALL BASED ON LEAKS
FROM THE INTEL COMMUNITY.
THAT WAS THE REASON FOR THE
EXTRACTION.
IN FACT, IN 2016 UNDER OBAMA,
THE CIA FIRST OFFERED TO EXTRACT
THIS SOURCE BECAUSE OF THE
MEDIA'S REPORTING.
IT DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
A GIFT TO THE INCOMING
ADMINISTRATION.
AND THEN, PRESIDENT OBAMA, HE
DECLASSIFIED AND PUBLICLY
RELEASED THE DNI REPORT ON
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE, WHICH
ALLUDED TO THIS SPY'S ROLE IN
THE KREMLIN.
IT ALL HAPPENED ON OBAMA'S
WATCH, NOW DONATED.
I WONDER WHY THAT DIDN'T MAKE
FAKE SEE     CNN'S HEADLINES.
FORMER CIA DIRECTOR,
MIKE POMPEO, HE WEIGHED IN,
CALLING THIS STORY MATERIAL
INACCURATE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE REPORTING IS MATERIALLY
INACCURATE.
YOU SHOULD KNOW, I DON'T TALK
ABOUT THINGS LIKE THIS VERY
OFTEN.
IT IS ONLY THE OCCASIONS WHERE
IT SOMETHING WHERE I THINK IT
PUTS PEOPLE AT RISK OR THE
REPORTING IS SO AGREED CHICK
EGREGIOUS.
I SUFFICE TO SAY THAT THE
REPORTING IS FACTUALLY WRONG.
>> Sean: FAKE NEWS PROUD OF
THIS POLITICAL HIT JOB PUTTING
AN OPERATIVE'S LIFE IN DANGER.
DOES ANYONE ON FAKES DOMINIC
FAKE NEWS CNN ACTUALLY CARE ABOT
FAKE NEWS CNN ACTUALLY CARE ABOE
FAKE NEWS CNN ACTUALLY CARE ABOU
FAKE NEWS CNN ACTUALLY CARE ABOH
OF ANYONE ANYMORE?
DESPITE ALL THESE GLARING ERRORS
IN THIS REPORTING, THIS B.S.
REPORTING, THE TWO NETWORKS, THE
DEDICATED HOURS AND HOURS OF
RECKLESS HYSTERICAL COVERAGE
ONCE AGAIN FOR WHAT WAS AN
OUTRIGHT LIE.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE'VE ALSO LEARNED, AND THIS
IS A CNN EXCLUSIVE THAT U.S.
INTELLIGENCE PULLED A VERY HIGH
LEVEL OUT OF RUSSIA.
PARTLY BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE
PRESIDENT MISHANDLED CLASSIFIED
INTELLIGENCE.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> THE CIA EXTRACTED THE SPY, IN
PARTS OF FEARS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP MIGHT LEAK
INFORMATION.
SEE ONE OF COURSE, SOME OF THE
VERY WORST COVERAGE BY THE CHIEF
CONSPIRACY THEORIST, RACHEL
MADDOW.
PER USUAL, HER REPORTING WAS
DOWNRIGHT THEATRICAL.
BY THE WAY.
I'VE GOT THE TAX RETURNS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT THE CNN REPORT IS SAYING
THAT NBC NEWS AND
"NEW YORK TIMES" IS THAT AS
PRESIDENT, TRUMPS SO EGREGIOUSLY
MISHANDLED CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AND SO DOING,
DESTROYED HIGHLY SENSITIVE,
HIGHLY EFFECTIVE FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE AGENTS BY TELLING
THE RUSSIANS ABOUT IT.
>> Sean: THEIR OBSESSIVE
COVERAGE OF THE STORY.
RACHEL MADDOW.
THEY FURTHER EXPOSED, THINK
ABOUT THIS, THE EXTRACTED SPY.
I WONDER IF SHE IS GOING TO
APOLOGIZE FOR PUTTING THIS MAN
AND HIS FAMILY IN JEOPARDY,
BECAUSE, YES, BASICALLY AND ARM
OF PROPAGANDA, THEY TRACKED DOWN
THIS GUY'S HOME ADDRESS.
THEY ACTUALLY KNOCKED ON HIS
DOOR.
KEEP IN MIND, PUTIN HAS
DEVELOPED A HOSTILE ACT.
THE HOSTILE REGIME.
WHILE THAT GUY RIGHT THERE, HE
HAS DEVELOPED QUITE THE
REPUTATION FOR MURDERING DOUBLE
AGENTS ALL OVER THE WORLD,
INCLUDING THE UNITED KINGDOM.
THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO MATTER TO
THE MEDIA MOB, NOW DOES IT?
LET ME MAKE THIS CLEAR.
WITH THIS FAKE NEWS MOB, WITH
THESE CONSPIRACY THEORISTS DID
HERE, NOW IT'S GREAT, IT DIDN'T
TAKE TWO AND A HALF YEARS TO
EXPOSE THIS CONSPIRACY.
WHAT THEY DID IS PUT THIS GUY'S
FAMILY AND HIS LIFE IN DANGER.
WHY?
WELL, ONLY THEY CAN ANSWER.
OF COURSE, YOU HAVE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION THAT CREATED THIS
DISASTER.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE PREDICATE IS
WHAT IT ALWAYS IS.